some people say it smells like decaying
garbage or rotten meat or smelly feet
but nope it's stinky tofu
stinky tofu has been fermented and gives
off an intense smell while mostly found
as a street food throughout china here
in taipei one woman has given the stink
a home
what it means
and a good stink all starts with a good
brine
what's up
um
moral of the story don't judge a dish by
its stink
welcome to rochester new york the home
of kodak eastman situated on lake
ontario and creator of the finest
delicacy in all the land hey can you
have a play with all the garbage on it
please
that my friends is the garbage plate and
let me tell you it is glorious
my name is alex tahu my grandfather
invented the original garbage plate
called hotsome potatoes and my father
perfected the real garbage plate at this
point you're probably wondering what
this so-called garbage plate is i'll
tell you a garbage plate is
let me handle this
garbage plate starts with your choice of
sides from home fries french fries
macaroni salad or beans
and you pick your meat hot dogs
hamburgers cheeseburgers whatever's on
the menu then you add your toppings from
mustard onions and hot sauce ketchup and
red hot is optional then add two pieces
of italian bread and butter and you're
all set to go over the years we've had a
lot of different kind of garbage plates
we actually had our sardine plate years
ago i don't think it could get much
crazier than sardines
the best part of this business is of
course the customers without them would
be nothing the place was established to
give people a lot of food at a
reasonable price
for years people have come in here
hungry that didn't have any money my
father always fed them that's really
sweet alex but let's get back to the
garbage because i'm really wondering how
many calories are in a plate i really
don't know some people have said three
thousand i don't think it's that high
but i guess i'd have to be a
nutritionist to tell you
but i will say this is the only place
you can get a garbage plate any other
plate in rochester is a copycat we
trademarked it so now it's world famous
trademarking garbage
genius
universe
for example
products
foreign
is
is
most people think this fruit smells
terrible
it's been described using words like
rotting onions or raw sewage
not this guy though
it's a very good smell to me
my name is chang tekseng they call me
duran singh
i'm a farmer until now nearly 30 years
selling durian that's why they call me
duran singh
if you're not that familiar with durian
it has a spiky rind and the inside
is a yellow soft colored creamy fruit
it's native to southeast asia and
because of its odor is actually banned
from many public places
durian is forbidden in airport in hotel
some places they put a sign age that no
durian allow
the smell you can't hide
my record is about 100 feet
i can smell durant
besides having a distinctive smell
durian also has a distinctive taste it's
like a peanut caramel they have five
flavor a sweet flavor
alcohol flavor
bitter flavor flour flavor and nam taste
daughter of five flavor
numb taste literally means your mouth
will go numb
wow i can feel the numbness freshly
dropped durant the flavor is so good
even the bees come to the durant this
may well be my new favorite fruit people
in general are divided on this fruit
those who love it
love it the durian is so tasty it's
really good it's much better than it
smells
if you really like durant
there can be
like some people may look like crazy
like breakfast lunch dinner three meals
are all durant they can eat five seven
fruits per day
and there are others who just can't get
past the smell um
i smell like or what they chase
for durian sang it is the perfect fruit
either you like it or you hate it
some people they don't give chance to
taste
but you've got to try once in your
lifetime
so these are jellied eels eels in jelly
jelly
eels
and these are eels with no jelly like
loads of eels drawers of eels
hold on to your seats this might get a
bit weird
so we got this giant jiggly bowl of
jelly deals from this guy
my name is john chilvers i work for mix
hill supply in billingscape fish market
we supply live hills to the catering
trade public i've been selling eels for
33 years since i left school
so we've got some lovely eels here
these are all farmed in holland
but they're like the rolls royce of the
dylan hills
they're very very slippery
like some of their customers
back in the 18th century london's river
thames was crawling with these eels
nowadays john is one of the last few ill
suppliers in london
so john why were they so popular
yeah you need to speak to one of the
older fishmongers for that
oh uh
okay then
i'm 72 years old and i eat it every day
perfect so frank of bradley's fish
supply what made them so popular back
then so those days it was it was no
brainer everybody at jelly deals it was
an easy source to get very simple you
put a hook out and they catch themselves
eels are really edible and they were
full of goodness the people didn't
realize it then but they were they were
eating a real good product and we didn't
have indian chinese takeaway kebabs
everything else so it was a it was a
source of food so how do you make them
quite easy to prepare you to head off
guts out chop them in pieces then we
cook them
the process of cooking is more of an art
you need them to be very soft but if you
go past being soft all you've got is
mash thanks frank
so pie shop owner kane what do they go
well with jelly deals and stew deals are
very traditional with pine russian
liquor in the east end of london so
um you know it's not for everybody the
world's changing a little bit you do
either like them or hate them
probably in the old days we would go
through uh maybe 50 or 60 bowls of hills
a week probably now we might do 10 or
12. so if you think about food around
the world you think about paris and
their baguettes new york you think about
the pizzas the new york cheesecakes
that's what they're synonymous for
london the traditional food in london is
pine nationals that is a staple diet and
the taste
it's like eating basically a chunky
white fish
it must be long
it must be